hello everyone my name is emily and this
is some sub a channel all about survival
in the online jungle be honest do you
also sometimes have the desire to take a
little peek into the life of a person
that you used to be close to
but for whatever reason went your
separate ways
maybe it's an old pal a childhood friend
an ex-girlfriend or boyfriend
now this desire to be a little bit nosy
is made all the more tempting by the
fact that it's not difficult at all just
a couple of clicks and you already know
how they're getting on thanks facebook
and instagram and even if you're happy
with your current friends and partners
the temptation to fantasize about what
might have been is sometimes too great
thoughts might creep into your head
along the lines of and what if back then
we'd
now thankfully most of us will simply
close these pages without trying to
remind ourselves of the past
but unfortunately not everyone does this
unexpectedly a person from the past can
appear out of the blue and seriously
complicate your life according to the
pew research center four in ten
americans were victims of online
harassment last year
this harassment could be associated with
political views racial intolerance or
just plain jealousy
and if you're a young girl then there's
an even higher chance in fact 30 percent
that you've experienced sexual
harassment online
these numbers are really quite scary it
shows that any one of us can become a
victim of cyber criminals which means
it's time to act today i'm going to talk
about how to protect yourself if you
become the object of attention of a
cyberstalker
[Music]
now cyber stalkers differ somewhat from
the other predators that we often find
in the online jungle and they're not
interested in your money of course they
might try to blackmail you but the main
goal is different to either become a
part of your life or destroy it it
doesn't matter what these criminals are
doing whether they're watching your
activities or your movements trying to
give you a bad name or impersonating you
the key thing is that they are waiting
for a response so therefore remember the
main rule do not enter into any kind of
correspondence or communication with a
stalker asking them to leave you alone
or threatening to seek help from friends
or the police will only further provoke
the criminal his goal is your emotions
deprive him of the opportunity to
receive a prize first of all let's start
by taking care of your social networks
completely deleting your profiles is a
reliable but inconvenient option
without facebook or instagram page it
will be much more difficult to maintain
relationships with your friends and
colleagues deleting your profile will
also most likely just provoke the
criminal further he'll see this as his
first victory
some stalkers go even further they
create pages impersonating you which
copy your photos and videos they send
friend requests and messages to your
friends and then use these profiles to
discredit you if you delete your real
page yourself the stalker will only
thank you but let's not panic just
choose the highest privacy settings for
each of your social media pages
let only your very closest friends and
family see your information by the way
this is a great way to cut down your
friend list how many friends do you have
on facebook 300 500 a thousand even do
you really know all of these people or
at least more than just their names i
highly doubt it in the mid 90s british
anthropologist robin dunbar noticed a
pattern that the number of stable social
connections in primates is limited by
the physical capabilities of the brain
large monkeys have about 80 such
connections therefore a person whose
brain is much more developed can have
more friends somewhere between 100 to
230. this concept has been criticized
more than once but nonetheless the
developers of social networks have been
guided by the dunbar number for a long
time especially when evaluating
resources for their upcoming projects in
addition scientists from montreal notice
a link between the number of friends on
facebook and stress levels teenagers who
have more than 300 friends produce much
more of the stress hormone cortisol
during the day having too much of this
hormone can risk bringing on a serious
bouts of depression therefore work
through your friends list carefully
delete everyone you haven't talked to
since last christmas and of course there
should be no exes on this list rejected
partners often use social media posts to
attract attention to themselves this is
easy to understand the algorithms of
social networks regularly show them
people who they used to communicate with
a lot
constant reminders of an ex-partner
provoke interest but also make the split
more painful
a special category is old classmates
even if you graduated from high school
just a couple of years ago don't be
afraid to remove your former classmates
from your friends often a real monster
can be hiding behind the mask of an
inconspicuous schoolmate
meet matthew hardy
he is one of the most infamous cyber
stalkers in the uk in january 2022 he
was sentenced to nine years in prison
for the cyber stalking of multiple women
his first crimes were committed against
his classmates all the way back in 2009
at that time facebook was still very
much unfamiliar territory for the police
and the initial appeals against him were
ignored impunity encouraged matthew to
commit new crimes over the years the
police have recorded more than 100
statements from 62 victims the guilty
verdict included just nine of them
so it's highly likely that there are
more trials awaiting matthew
you know i remember going to bed with a
baseball bat for example and sleeping
with my phone in one hand and a baseball
bat next to my bed because i was so
terrified but going back to the
protection of your social networks a
more time consuming but better option
for protecting your social media
presence is to create another profile
use an alias that's not associated with
your real name date of birth or place of
residence
as an avatar you should choose something
abstract as unrelated to you as possible
then invite your closest friends to this
profile and use the old one exclusively
for official communication
delete all personal photos post videos
from your old profile and leave only the
bare minimum of official information
about your college or your university
places of work and professional
successes your original account will
still come in handy of course when
you're looking for a new job or suddenly
attract the attention of aml specialists
of course disable the ability to comment
a stalker can sometimes leave unpleasant
messages under old posts now at this
point the attacker will probably start
bombarding you with messages via dm
don't answer them but take screenshots
of all the messages right away record
the date and the time that you receive
them in the absolute worst case scenario
this will all be useful to you in court
in fact it was such recordings made by
one of hardy's victims that help prove
his guilt simply blocking and reporting
a user rarely helps
attackers often use a large number of
fake accounts
if you've become the object of interest
of such a criminal be prepared for the
fact that he may start sending messages
not only to you
but also to your loved ones perhaps even
from an account impersonating you
be sure to warn that you've become a
victim of a cyber criminal there's
absolutely no need to try and hide it or
feel ashamed by it in this case honesty
is the best policy
now with facebook everything is
relatively straightforward but let's try
to take a look at yourself through the
eyes of a cyber stalker try to collect
as much information about yourself as
you can from open sources if you want a
guide on how to carry out such a search
my colleague bradley spoke about it in a
separate video about orsint
check it out and carefully repeat his
steps with yourself as the target
this way you can come to understand just
how much criminals can find out about
you
so the first step is to google yourself
something i'm sure we've all done before
but check your real first name and
surname as well as on your social media
pages your name might be found on your
employer's website or in regional news
and press releases information in the
media most likely can't do you any harm
and as a rule you can arrange with your
employer to remove information about
your place of work from public access if
you want to remove mentions of yourself
from google search altogether use the
link to the special requests form i'll
leave a link to it down below so you can
check it out if you want to if you
didn't find anything out of the ordinary
try searching for a pseudonym or a
username known to the attacker
for example
search by email address or buy an old
nickname
sites and forums that you have long
forgotten about may appear in the search
it doesn't matter if it's a review for a
hotel in the mountains or a forum about
firearms delete all of your old posts
and messages
even with these small pieces of
information an attacker can find out a
lot about your hobbies travels and
possible friends
why let them get their hands on such
information now let's turn to taking
care of information brokers radaris
spokeo intelius and the like
these companies collect and systematize
information about all of us from the
internet mass media and also have access
to databases of credit institutions and
government services i recommend
regularly checking information about
yourself with info brokers
this will help to identify another
possible method that cyber stalkers may
employ now you probably know the name
tim cook
he now holds the position of ceo of
apple but he also runs the clinic safe
sex clinic cook hiv now of course cook
himself was completely unaware of this a
company with this name was registered in
california by tim's pursuer julia lee
choi a 45 year old resident of virginia
she sent letters to cook informing him
that he was the father of her twins
demanded 500 million and threatened to
burn down his house the registration of
dozens of strange companies was just one
element of her harassment apple's
lawyers properly resolved this issue and
removed these companies from the
register but the list still includes
enterprises with unexpected founders
queen elizabeth ii
microsoft ceo satya nadella and julia
lee choi herself so don't be surprised
if you suddenly find yourself as the
founder of some strange business after
the incident with cook other cyber
criminals began to adopt this method
now
novice stalkers don't usually turn to
information brokers but experienced
criminals can definitely make use of
their services
therefore be sure to remove yourself
from such databases
american and european legislation
provides a procedure for the deletion of
this data
but brokers comply with it in quite a
formal way to delete data about yourself
you'll have to first confirm your
identity and then fill out a number of
forms that are not located in the most
obvious places manually it can take a
lot of time so you might be better off
using one of the online services that
does this for you such as delete me we
talked about their work in detail about
a year ago but let's return to what can
be done here and now
[Music]
be sure to change all of your passwords
start with the most important ones for
your icloud your gmail and then work
down to things such as old gaming
accounts
if you're being stalked by someone you
know or a former partner this should be
your first step if the criminal doesn't
know you personally then it's not such a
high priority if possible use services
with two-factor authentication this will
reduce the likelihood of someone hacking
your accounts carry out an audit of your
smartphone and computer
an experienced stalker could have
installed malicious software on them
most often this is done with the help of
phishing attacks
imagine that you received a message with
a link to an archive that apparently
contains your private photos most users
will download and open this file without
thinking of course instead of photos
you'll receive spyware that the stalker
can use to monitor you you should delete
all unfamiliar applications or even
better reset your smartphone to factory
settings and manually reinstall the ones
you need this won't just help protect
you but has the added benefit of freeing
up a whole lot of memory space
make it a rule not to answer calls from
unknown numbers and don't exchange
messages with strangers cyber stalkers
like to use a lot of fake phone numbers
and accounts you should also review your
old photos and videos consider what will
happen if some of them fall into the
hands of an attacker now be aware i'm
not talking about those photos of you
with a snapback and that justin
bieber-esque hairstyle i'm talking about
photos that are perhaps intimate or
compromising in some way
you should prepare for the worst imagine
what will happen if they're used against
you
think about how you can try to mitigate
the damage for example by talking about
their possible publication with your
friends and family in advance now if you
suspect that stalker is somehow
receiving information about your
movements check your car bike backpack
or bag for the presence of someone
else's air tag
these apple devices are now in high
demand among cyber criminals it's easy
to place them on another person
unnoticed thankfully there are several
free apps available to search for such
tags so scan your stuff with them
regularly any unfamiliar tag is a valid
reason to get yourself down to the
police station pronto
[Music]
now the main thing that you should know
is that you must not succumb to threats
or blackmail don't make any deals with a
stalker
once they've found your weak spot
they'll put pressure on it again and
again and again the stalker doesn't need
your money he needs a place in your life
he sees these people living their happy
lives online and tries to make a
connection with them there is then a
rejection the defendant feels which then
triggers a lashing out now this is how
the stalker's thinking was described by
matthew harding's lawyer who we talked
about a little bit earlier in the video
do you think you can really reason with
such a person no
therefore the problem needs to be solved
radically once and for all if you are
the victim of a stalker collect as much
evidence as possible and contact the
police now in the post-covered world the
police are much better versed in modern
technologies than just a couple of years
ago
not long ago officers often simply
brushed off such statements but now more
and more cases are making it to court
even if the stalker left you alone this
probably means he just turned his
attention to another victim
so don't let him stay free
take action and fight for your safety
okay that's all for today guys thanks
for watching my name is emily and this
was some sub your guide to the online
jungle see you again next time
[Music]
you